hey youtubers it's Charlie so we finally
learned who that mystery new flash is so
there's just gonna be a breakdown of
what the producers have said in his
story from the comics there's also a
whole bunch of other really awesome news
so since I made my flash trailer video
they actually came out and said who this
is they actually the producers revealed
his Toddla sands from Vampire Diaries
playing a version of the rifle but very
clearly he looks like he's from the
Wally West era just his costume is much
more modern looking he's young but a lot
of you read the comics know that the
rival is edward clariss the Jay Garrick
era reverse-flash in fact that version
of the reverse-flash were a yellow and
red costume just like eobard thawne
ended up doing much much later so if
you've seen some of the things that the
TV show has done the last few seasons by
mixing and matching parts of people's
backstories with plot elements from more
recent things in the comics then you
kind of have an idea of what they're
doing with the rifle on the TV show so
he is not the big bad he's just like the
mid bad Savitt are is the big bad of the
season so you know much much worse the
things that he'll be doing this
character the rival might be connected
to sabotage speed cult and I'm guessing
for the most part he'll have his own
evil plan he's trying to bring to
fruition and what I'm hoping is is that
we see a lot of cross talk with Jay
Garrick from earth 3 now John Wesley
Shipp appears in the trailer that I
posted last night but that could be the
Henry Allen that could be Jay Garrick
wearing plain clothes since Barry is not
really close to Joe anymore flashpoint
Joe isn't friends with Barry he needs
someone that can be an adviser so they
said that's kind of what Jay Garrick is
gonna do this season when he pops up
every once in a while he'll just offer
Barry advice as Jay Garrick of the
comics does with the younger versions of
the flash like Wally West Barry Allen
he's been the flash a lot longer so some
of these other villains he may have run
into we don't really know how long's
avatar has been around and which modern
plot elements they're gonna use from the
comics for the rival because in the
classic versions of the comics the
edward clariss rival created velocity 9
but they use velocity 9 during season 2
for the zoom plot so most of what the
rival is doing on the TV show if it is
very comic book II a comic book plot I'm
expecting to come from the more modern
Wally West era because that's where most
of sabotage stuff is
coming from in fact I'm really
interested to see how much Deep Space
nine stuff they end up doing because if
you've seen Deep Space nine you kind of
remember that gold ducat try to ascend
to godhood with the help of evil
wormhole aliens the pah-wraiths
and they were going to kill the good
wormhole aliens so on the flash TV show
we've met the Speed Force wormhole
aliens maybe sabotage trying to become
one with them like he is in the comics
maybe they're just doing a carbon copy
of his comic book plot or maybe it's
more Deep Space nine and we'll see like
the negative Speed Force because that is
something from the comics but they'll
leave that in pah-wraiths style from
Deep Space Nine and they'll try to kill
off these good Speed Force wormhole
aliens but make no mistake
savat are what he ends up doing will be
way worse than what the rival ends up
doing so like the rival looks like a
character who's just gonna like walk up
and punch you in the face that sucks
butts avatar looks like someone who's
going to try and poison the source of
all your power so imagine all the good
speedsters and all the evil speedsters
drink from the Fountain of Youth like
they gained some secret power from the
secret fountain Sava tar is trying to
poison the fountain so it is a really
good excuse for all the evil speedsters
that we've seen to team up with the good
speedsters but there's there's so much
more going on they're taking a more Game
of Thrones style approach with their TV
narrative where you have like a bunch of
big characters but you don't see all of
them every single episode so like you
see Jon Snow in a couple Game of Thrones
episodes but then you go away and you
see a different group of characters so
I'm just expecting them to do that with
some of their big characters they're
bringing on like you have the Rogues
like Captain Cold they've been teasing a
mirror master versus Captain Cold rogue
war this season but clearly it's not
gonna happen in every single episode so
you'll have like this really big thing
going on with the Rogues in a couple
episodes then they'll go away then
slightly bigger storyline the rival will
come on do something then he'll go away
for a few episodes we'll pick up with
sabot our of all the plots that I'm
expecting to extend to the back half of
the season I think they'll be the rival
in the Savitt our plot this avatar plot
will be like one of the few that goes
across the entire season but like
gorilla City that's another good example
that's probably going to be
a relatively self-contained two-part
episode she's because it's really
expensive
all that CG that they're gonna have to
do they'll probably introduce Sola bar
so just think about the way Game of
Thrones plots its episodes out like you
have big plots then you have micro plots
that only go over a couple episodes
they'll be doing that way more this
season which I think I'll be a lot more
fun like they'll tee up a big arc with
the Rogues
they'll resolve that relatively quickly
and then they'll come back later the
same thing will happen with the rival
the slow burn will be Savitt are like
you know you get a tease for the speed
cult then we'll slowly learn about what
he looks like who he is what his
backstory is then we get to the back
half when we refocus on that where it's
like team flash versus savat are and his
speed cold so if you want to do some
homework for the flash I would actually
recommend you go back and read some Mark
Waid era wally west comics but as with
all things they tend to change comic
book plots they mix and match names so
whenever we get two episodes I'll just
explain like what they're doing like
okay the rival here
he created velocity-9 he's from the
Golden Age but what he's doing on the TV
show is from the Wally West era of the
comics so it's gonna be really fun to
try and pick all the Easter eggs out I'm
really really happy about this season so
far let me know in the comments though
what do you think that the rivals plan
is this season and do you think that he
is connected to sabotage speed cult or
do you think he's going to be completely
separate there is a giveaway that's been
going on now I'll say congratulations to
parish you win this round is a $20
Amazon gift card please be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details because there's so much DC stuff
dropping they'll be dropping more
trailers soon I'm just gonna keep the
giveaway going all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so get height
they'll probably be some Thor stuff
later tonight there was this picture of
Odin looks like he clocked a lot of city
miles since Thor the dark world they
just announced they're doing a
live-action Justice League movie in the
DC Cinematic Universe so like I've been
doing a lot of Justice League videos
this will connect to those movies it's
part of that universe and they announced
that Dan Harmon is punching up the
Doctor Strange script adding scenes so
they are going to Cronenberg the
out of the Marvel Cinematic Universe if
you haven't seen Rick and Morty be sure
to watch Rick
morty because the Marvel and DC movie
universes are going out of control in
the best possible way there's also a new
arrow trailer video for season 5 so a
whole bunch of videos I'll try to get
them all out as fast as possible while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for that flash trailer video
again and you can click here to learn
all about guardians of the galaxy volume
2 thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight